im berliner stadtteil treptow league
diese neue durchgangsstraße tag für tag
fahren hier tausende autos entlang 2005
wird die straße mitten durch das
produktionsgelände der späten baumschule
gezogen die berliner sohn besser zur
autobahn kommen
trotzdem erklärt die stadt den
autobahnzubringer zur anliegerstraße mit
unglaublichen folgen als einziger
anlieger muss die baumschulen und satte
100.000 euro straßenreinigungsgebühren
nach zahlen der baumschule chef kann es
kaum glauben wo ich zum ersten mal davon
gehört habe habe ich gesagt na das kann
ja nicht
es kann ja nicht sein und das wird auch
nicht passieren weil ich mir nicht
vorstellen konnte dass irgendjemand in
der stadt berlin das durch drückt laut
berliner verwaltung logik handelt es
sich bis hierhin um eine ganz normale
durchgangsstraße da muss keiner gebühren
zahlen
ab hier erklärt die stadt die strecke
zur anliegerstraße für diese 300 meter
soll die baumschule pro jahr
17.000 euro blechen dieses straßen
mysterium verstehen viele berliner
überhaupt nicht
die müssen wie geld machen
also lassen sich da irgendetwas
einfallen ob das sinn macht oder nicht
sind völliger blödsinn ihr in berlin von
den entscheidungsträgern auf die idee
gekommen ist dieses straßenstück die
neue straße als anliegerstraße zu
klassifizieren
sollte sich nur mal einen tag
frühmorgens und auch nur abends zur
rushhour zeiten nicht hinstellen und
einfach mal die autos zählen aber von
der stadt hat hier anscheinend noch
keine autos gezählt und bei der berliner
stadtreinigung verweist man auf die
vorschriften schriftlich heißt es die
bsr vollzieht gesetzliche regelungen sie
hat alle ihr zur verfügung stehenden
rechtlichen möglichkeiten intensiv
geprüft leider mit negativem ergebnis
daraufhin prüfte die baumschule intensiv
ihre rechtlichen möglichkeiten
schmetterte die bäume und gab das feld
vor kurzem an einen bauern abgeerntet
hier künftig heuer muss dafür keine
straßenreinigung bezahlen
17.000 euro jährliche gebühren für die
baumschule 0 euro in auf der fläche heu
gemacht wird auf die idee muss man erst
mal kommen
man kann überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen
warum wieso weshalb also für mich ist
das einfach nur unüberlegt ich finde es
unmöglich ehrlich gesagt ich verstehe es
nicht
die bäume sind gefällt die baumschule
ist an der straße gar kein anlieger mehr
jetzt muss ein gericht entscheiden ob
holger zahn tatsächlich hunderttausend
euro gebühren nachzahlen muss